python is a strong high-level
object-oriented programming language
today python is used by many big giants
such as intel ibm nasa pixar netflix
facebook jp morgan spotify and many
other companies
its features have made it popular and
widely used across the globe python is
one of the four main languages used at
google
google's youtube is largely written in
python and it's the same with reddit
pinterest and instagram
python is an open source easy to code
dynamically typed programming language
and also featured as interpreted and
integrated language
there are two popular python versions
python 2 and python 3. to stay up with
modern software development processes
each release of the python language
introduces beneficial new functionality
also python can be used for various
tasks outside of software development it
benefits researchers data scientists qr
engineers and devops specialists
so if you want to get introduced to the
important concepts and skills needed for
interview preparation we are here to
help you with that simply learn skill of
course getting python interview ready
will give you all the necessary skills
and experience to get your desired
python job you are probably curious
about the course's content so let me
make you through the process
the getting python interview ready
course will help you crack a job in
python it will take you through all the
questions that can be expected from a
python developer with answers explained
in hindi you will learn about list
comprehension in python plan the
function in python and the difference
between python list and tuple and many
such concepts further you will have an
interview question series in which you
will learn questions and answers with
python basics and advanced topics that
will help you get your desired parking
job
the video lectures that you find as a
part of this getting past an interview
ready series are created by shubham he
is an industry expert who share his
knowledge and experience with many
college students pressures and
associates
he has his regular visits to sim voices
and mit pune college he has a youtube
channel that creates videos dedicated to
devops python and interview preparation
this getting python interview ready
course is two hours long and old
chapters are self-paced video lessons
with 90 days of access you can learn at
your own pace and your own convenience
simply learn will issue you a course
certification once you have completed
the course
this certificate can be included on your
resume to help you get hired isn't that
amazing
there are no such prerequisites to start
with getting python interview ready
course but you must have a basic
understanding of the language the
getting python interview ready course
has been designed to cater intermediates
to get ready for the interview process
so what are you waiting for head to your
scale up page and enrich your python
programming knowledge by enrolling in
our getting python interview ready
course today
sign up now and get certified with
simply learn the link is in the
description box below
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here